[Music]
synonymous with love commitment and
devotion precious diamonds assess on top
of over three-quarters of all engagement
rings Americans alone spent 11 billion
dollars on wedding jewelry every year
but it's actually a pretty recent
phenomenon here's the real reason we buy
diamonds once a very rare gem vast
diamond reserves were found in South
Africa in the late 19th century diamond
diggers line up ready for the word go in
the later South African diamond drew one
of many prospectors seeking to make
their fortune was Englishman Cecil
Rhodes he formed the De Beers company in
1888 eventually took charge of much of
the diamond trade including mining
supply and distribution but diamond
sales dropped off during the Great
Depression of the 1930s
so DeBeers turned to another burgeoning
industry for help 1938 De Beers
commissioned ad agency NWA air and Sun
with making diamonds and necessary
luxury in American lives De Beers his
grip on the supply mean that whoever
sold the diamond was likely selling one
of theirs the agency decided they had to
convey the idea that diamonds were a
gift of love men had to be convinced the
larger and more beautiful the diamond
the greater the show of love and women
had to view diamonds as an integral part
of caution the agency went to Hollywood
tasking producer Margaret Essen Joe was
reinforcing the image of the diamond as
integral to love
she influenced changing the movie title
diamonds are dangerous to adventure in
diamonds and she supplied jewelry for
stars like Mel Oberon and Claudette
Colbert to wear on-screen Ettinger's
cousin
Louella Parsons was a powerful gossip
columnist and also on the payroll her
articles started paying particular
attention to the love lives of the stars
featuring well staged pictures of
engagement rings while focusing on
lavish and aspirational jewels like
Grace Kelly's a 12 carat square cut
diamond engagement ring
they became symbols of upward mobility
anyone could aspire to become like a
movie star or a princess with their own
diamond De Beers even managed to get
into schools and churches to discuss the
history of diamonds their true intention
sowing the seed with children the
diamond engagement rings were part of
marriage and that it was a tradition by
the 1940s as America's men went off to
war a number of marriages started to
rise between 1938 and 1941 diamond sales
went up 55% they are also used work by
great painters like Picasso and Dali in
their posters to associate the diamond
with a piece of classic art but it was a
simple ad line that was to make the
biggest impact in 1947 pea copywriter
Frances Gerety came up with a slogan a
diamond is forever and the association
with eternal love was solidified it's
appeared in every DeBeers advert since
1948 and it's been heralded as the
advertising slogan of the century it was
so successful Garrity worked on every
DeBeers campaign until 1970 shortly
after it was immortalized in the Bond
film of the same name
what the slogan did was create the
concept that a diamond ring would be
kept by the betrothed for eternity
creating a special sentiment but also
meaning fewer would be resold therefore
increasing the chance for DeBeers to
sell more freshly mined stones a as
copywriters were also skilled in
directing consumer spending habits
suggesting a month's salary was a good
amount to spend on a ring then upping it
to two by the 1980s before the Second
World War ten percent of engagement
rings contain diamonds by the 1980s the
number was up to 80 percent over the
same period diamond sales in the United
States grew from 23 million dollars to
2.1 billion
DeBeers and NWA s and Sons marketing
masterpiece played on our emotions so
powerfully that not only were they able
to sell as a product we didn't need but
they influenced the culture of marriage
[Music]
you